[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show so everybody's
jumping in now on what billionaires
could be doing and how much in taxes we
could be collecting from billionaires
all because of
the various proposals none of which now
we've learned are actually going to be
part of the new uh infrastructure
spending build that is moving forward
but because of all the different
proposals about how to tax billionaires
in a serious manner
um now the world food program says hey
you know what
if we got a one-time six billion dollar
donation
from elon musk
jeff bezos other billionaires
we could save 42 million people from
starvation now i think that this is a
very interesting story because
it's not news
that we could solve hunger like
we've been saying for a really long time
on this show and it's been known for a
really long time we actually have all
the resources we need to solve hunger if
you just look at calories grown per day
on the planet and number of people the
numbers work now of course you've got to
start taking away from that
spoilage
carbon footprint so some of these
calories might have to be relocated
really far you know there's obviously
logistical things to figure out but the
point pad is
we've known that solving hunger is just
a decision it's like do we do it
some will say well okay david yes in
some general sense like we have the
money and we have the calories but it is
a big undertaking and i don't deny that
but the people surprised like wow
6 billion could save 42 million people
like yes we've been saying this all
along the question is actually getting
the political will and the logistical
infrastructure in order to actually do
it
yeah we have to get the whole world on
the same team which can be tough to do
especially when we're all going through
our own crises like of course covet is
still a big issue now and the us has
these budgetary issues a lot of these
budgetary issues are made up right
because we don't have to spend as much
as we do on the military we could
relocate some of these funds but we just
decide not to and so it's interesting
how now the world food program director
is appealing to billionaires instead of
governments saying
okay well these governments are tapped
out of resources or they're just
unwilling to do so so maybe elon musk
jeff bezos you could make a contribution
and we can solve world hunger and i
understand why the director is doing
this whether or not these billionaires
are actually going to take that person
up on the offer that's a different
question the other question is
just because the the any organization
says here's what it would cost doesn't
mean that if you hand that organization
the money they actually have the
resources and the wherewithal to do it
i'm not saying one way or the other i'm
conceding that it's not as simple as we
decide to end hunger today and next week
it's done but
if you start kind of categorizing first
these 42 million people are the ones at
most dire
straits uh when it comes to starvation
taking care of those 42 million
would be about a six billion dollar
endeavor period you really start to
think wow that's really not a lot of
money when you're thinking about the
global economy it would have to be a
recurring payment though right like i
have a tough time believing that there's
just a one-time payment of six billion
dollars and then that's it right i mean
i suppose you can set up the
infrastructure to make that happen but
it seems like it would have to be maybe
six billion dollars on an annual basis
whatever the number is that seems
incredibly slow it seems incredibly
small don't you think well i think part
of it is it's not just you buy food for
6 billion and ship it to people i think
part of the 6 billion includes creating
infrastructure for growing and producing
food in some of these areas like i think
i think it's it's
more than just hand food over to people
so hopefully some of it would contribute
to long-term food stability
and another thing that people often
bring up is housing right because we
hear statistics about how with a
one-time 80 billion dollar payment or
sometimes it's 50 billion dollars the
numbers can vary we can end homelessness
here in the us but it may not be that
straightforward of course because not
everyone wants to go to homeless
shelters sometimes you have to deal with
issues of drug abuse before you can
necessarily
deal with issues of shelter and so yeah
that money would do some good certainly
but it wouldn't wipe out homelessness
altogether i think donating to help
people eat that seems a little bit more
straightforward to me because i don't
know if there's these other compounding
factors that prevent people from getting
the food like if you're hungry you're
going to want to take people up on that
offer who are providing you the food
shelter may not necessarily be the same
thing yeah i would consider it i think
that you're right in that
it's let me let me see how i can say
this
it goes without saying
that at this point no one should be
going hungry on planet earth and it
should just be fixable like within a
year we should be able to fix it
homelessness is more complicated
in different ways we should still be
able to deal with it in the united
states but fixing global homelessness is
far more complicated i think that's
that's the point you're trying to make
both are fixable but the food thing
should just be like guys come on what
are we doing here and they both have to
be top priorities i mean i guess you can
put food ahead of shelter but both are
super super important and we'll have to
see if any of these billionaires take
the world food program director up on
the offer right not holding my breath
even though we hear about stories about
uh elon musk for example now being worth
about 230 240 billion dollars what's a
few 10 billion dollars right give or
take um but he probably will decide not
to do it because he considers his money
to be more valuable elsewhere and he
wants to keep it i think i think you're
absolutely right uh hey iran nuclear
deal is getting going um iran said
yesterday that by the end of november
it's going to go back to negotiating
around the 2015 nuclear deal this is the
deal that was signed when barack obama
was president donald trump just bailed
on it just did iran didn't violate it
they just bailed on it trump did rather
and iran's deputy foreign minister made
the announcement on twitter saying that
they are going to be uh re-engaging in
dialogue and negotiating before the end
of november exact date remains to be
announced up i think that this is a
really great thing the right hates the
deal
the truth is iran didn't violate it you
could have argued at the start the
deal's not strict enough or the deal
doesn't include enough oversight or it's
not enough wide reaching or whatever
but once the deal started we had no
reason to believe
that iran was violating the deal once
trump bailed on the deal we predicted
and so did others because it was so
obvious well now iran's going to want a
negotiating chip so now they probably
would be logically going back to doing
the research and the enrichment that
they were not supposed to be doing
believe that that indeed did start
happening and then now it looks like the
negotiations are going to restart so
do i think that the iran nuclear deal
was perfect no
do i think that there's always some
element of well why do these countries
get to decide
whether those countries get to have
nukes that being said i think that it is
different for some countries to have
them versus others although i am
generally speaking for nuclear
disarmament but putting all of that
stuff aside it was a pretty good deal
that iran was sticking with until trump
decided to just say we're done with it
and so i welcome this i do wonder what's
going to happen next though like even if
iran does come to the negotiating table
and they work out a deal that's similar
if not the same as the one that we had
signed back in what was it 2015.
then we could see a new president take
over in 2024 maybe a republican
president yeah someone like donald trump
or ron desantis and you know that
they're just going to pull out the deal
again and we've talked about how this is
a risk all along right and the word of
the us isn't really going to be worth
much if every four years we keep making
agreements and then backing out of them
i suppose that shouldn't stop us from
trying to make this agreement now right
because that would at least in the short
term do something good and you can't
predict the future you don't know for
sure that a trump type right-winger is
going to take over in a few years but
we'll just have to wait and see i
suppose the other thing that is almost
certainly going to become an issue is
that
diplomatic word in the united states is
that before the u.s re-engages
the u.s would stipulate that iran needs
to
fully come back into compliance and
prove that they're in compliance
in order to remove any of the sanctions
that are on iran whereas my expectation
would be that there would be other
negotiating parties and iran itself that
would say hold on a second you guys
bailed so we went back to doing some
stuff
we'll get back into compliance but we
need the sanctions to stop right away
we're not willing to sign a deal which
says oh in two years once you've
demonstrated you're in compliance then
the sanctions come off i think that
could become a sticking point where iran
says we will commit to getting into
compliance but you've got to drop the
sanctions now and the u.s may not agree
to that that could become a big
negotiating problem i mean i do think
that we have less leverage now because
we have the ones that pulled out of the
deal so yeah we're probably going to
have to make some concessions like that
and also i would imagine the us has to
take more of a back seat in these
negotiations and let other countries
like the uk france germany everyone else
involved do sort of the talking here and
the us can sign up just sort of sign on
to whatever the rest of these nations
come up with because at this point we
just have no legitimacy there's there's
no reason why we should be leading the
charge here which was exactly what we
said would be the problem longer term
when donald trump unilaterally bailed on
the deal so everything happening is
predicted everything happening is
predicted and now we'll have to just
wait and see one more thing about this
do you know how with nafta trump decided
to end that deal and then he signed uh
the usmca which was basically just the
same thing as nasa yeah slightly
rewarded are you surprised he didn't try
to do something similar with iran or do
you think it makes sense because it
irritated iran and the rest of the world
to such a degree where they weren't
willing to compromise with trump and go
back to the negotiating table i don't
think iran would have been willing to
say hey let's do the exact same thing
but call it something else to give trump
a political victory there's no way they
were gonna go for that yeah maybe mexico
and canada because they're seen as more
of our ally yeah be willing to do such a
thing but iran not not necessarily i get
that hey we've been covering the decline
in cigarette smoking in the united
states that's been taking place for
literally decades at this point in time
which is a great thing it's a very
welcome thing
uh cigarette sales increased last year
for the first time in two decades
tobacco companies uh spent more money on
marketing and the ftc said in its
cigarette report that almost 204 billion
cigarettes were sold last year
versus 203 billion cigarettes in 2019
now it's a modest increase but remember
we had been seeing a decline
now
the report doesn't say why this happened
but there's a couple different things we
can point to one um tobacco companies
cigarette companies spent more money on
marketing
and advertising and promotion
typically you get a return on that you
add very with with normal products you
advertise more as long as there's a
market for it if you spend more on
advertising you do more sales so that's
one explanation they also um
did some more bulk discounting in order
to make the cigarettes a little bit
cheaper so remember the number of
cigarettes sold went up total revenue
i'm less sure about that would be
something we have to look at
the
intuitive assumption is
stress of the pandemic
lockdowns
people saving money on other things and
thus buying more cigarettes are kind of
like intuitively the things that are
being pointed to the report doesn't
actually
say that but that's what's being kind of
um uh
suggested i think is the point i have
one more theory too which is that in
march of 2020 we saw a lot of
stockpiling right yeah buying a bunch of
toilet paper
and all these other things so maybe
cigarette smokers were buying a bunch of
cigarettes as well and so they had a big
stockpile that they purchased in march
of 2020 and that maybe to some extent uh
holds them over even until today could
be that's one other hope i suppose i'm
saying hope because we don't want to see
rates of cigarette smoking go back up
and you know it suggests that it is
maybe going back up slightly for seeing
the rates of purchasing go going back up
so you know hopefully this is just a
blip and then we go back down with the
rates of uh tobacco and cigarettes
purchase for this year but we just don't
know yet we we have just a little bit of
data for this year and it does seem that
for the period ending march 27 so
basically like q1 is is what they're
saying
um sales of cigarettes were back down
almost five percent which is great to
see now there's one other confounding
factor here which that is that over
recent years some of the decline in
regular cigarette purchases was replaced
by e-cigarettes and other
affiliated products i guess we would
call them um so some of it is
replacement but
there's there's actually e-cigarettes
which have also been declining most
recently so hopefully it's all going in
the right direction i don't know
yeah we know that e-cigarettes shouldn't
be seen as a replacement for smoking
regular cigarettes because they still
are unhealthy but it's proven at this
point that they are healthier right i
mean if i don't pick one or the other i
don't know i mean that that was my that
was my working belief for a very long
time i i just am not sure one way or the
other at this point yeah i mean with
cigarettes generally it took decades to
actually see the results of what
long-term smoking would be on the body
on the lungs and so maybe we have to
wait until e-cigarettes have been around
for a long time to really make some
assumptions and conclusions about the
effects of that but yeah i mean
everyone's sort of works with that
assumption and maybe it's our detriment
everyone thinks okay well obviously the
vapor is going to be less harmful than
the smoke is yeah and you know maybe
there are fewer carcinogens and all this
other stuff but perhaps we just don't
know yet yeah those are the alligators
are the assertions that are made i just
am so skeptical of the things any of
these companies say and i know that one
of the issues i think with the
e-cigarettes was that you might
unknowingly without realizing it even
though unlike a per
if you compare apples to apples it's
less bad but it makes it so easy to
consume way more
that it may not in practice the way it's
being used be any healthier i don't
something like that you know especially
because you can sort of sneak those and
vape those inside right oh that's right
we're doing that all the time some
people are on it like a baby bottle all
day
yeah yeah totally i mean i think
regardless of what we find out it's
going to be shown that the best things
to put into your lungs are nitrogen and
oxygen and we should leave some of this
other stuff out nitrogen there it is
there's an idea oh yeah um
i actually heard kids these days are
huffing nitrogen
yeah oh yeah it's it's it's big in the
atmosphere isn't it they love it they
absolutely love the most common gas in
the atmosphere and we think of something
else the bioavailability of it is very
very big
um okay
let's uh so what do we have coming up
next week
it oh so actually let me back up
tesla not tesla spacex has a launch this
sunday which i would normally love to
cover but it's scheduled for 2 21 in the
morning i'm not going to do a live
stream at 2 21 in the morning eastern
time but
with weather you know how it can get
delayed pat so if i wake up sunday
morning and the launch hasn't happened i
may do a stream
tuesday night we have the virginia
gubernatorial
elections
and um i will be live streaming those
results and there's others like i know
it's boston mayoral there's a few
there's a bunch of other races too isn't
there new jersey don't they have a
google earth race also but maybe that's
getting less coverage because it's a
solid blue state most of the time i
think you're right it is election day
everywhere just about so there there
should be some other races to follow
yeah it's going to be a pretty strong
stream i expect so that'll be on tuesday
and then as i've said before if donald
trump ends up going to virginia to
campaign for the republican candidate
there glenn younkin
who has been kind of keeping trump away
because it seems like it wouldn't be
particularly useful but trump said
something about we'll see you soon
virginia on his website yesterday
if a rally gets scheduled if anybody in
the audience sees it please let me know
because that's something i would like to
stream that would be an interesting you
know kind of like final event before
um the election and also if barack obama
or joe biden are going back to virginia
to campaign for terry mcauliffe i would
be interested in streaming that now pat
i know tomorrow you're going to be
talking about your upcoming odyssey it's
sort of like homer's odyssey do you want
to say anything about it today at all
yeah i'll talk more about it tomorrow i
anticipate but
the big news is that i'm going to be
going to florida for the next two months
or florida right which are you going to
i guess which because i need to know for
payroll back and forth
okay because uh unemployment insurance
through payroll is much higher in
florida than in florida so it's good to
know okay well we'll have to consider
all the different benefits and
everything there uh yeah so i'm actually
going to be driving down because of
course i'll need a car there so it's
really quite the odyssey it's going to
take a couple days to get down there
and so i'm going to be spending the
weekend driving down there on a solo
road trip that should be fun maybe
you'll have some stories from that and
then i'm going to be uh renting out a
place in florida uh for those two months
up until the end of the year holidays
it's near the beach it has a pool should
be fun it's really just to get away more
than anything else to escape the cold up
in the northeast it's not for any
political reasons or anything like that
but yeah i think it's going to be a good
time i also am planning on being in
warmer climates in december although i
am not planning to go to
florida or florida i'm going to try to
stick to blue states if i can if i can
although i know florida is very 50 50.
well you can come visit i mean we can
hang out together and maybe even do the
show in the same location like we used
to do do they even allow jews in that
part of florida because it's not miami
you know it's it's a totally different
sort of thing well you'll be allowed in
my house okay not in the area you'll be
allowed there um on the trip down are
you bringing soylent or are you planning
to stop at diners drive-ins and dives
i have one bottle left
of soylent and i'm going to bring it
with me just in case
but it's going to be a lot of outside
food i think for the next couple of days
and then maybe i'll have to put in
another soylent order once i get down
there will you wear a mask if you dine
indoors and say the trip takes you
through south carolina
no i don't want to get beat up i mean
i'm not going to wear a mask i don't
know we'll have to see i'm sure it's not
going to be required of me anywhere i go
uh but i'll i'll play it by ear you can
probably sit outdoors also at wherever
you're going to yeah
all right good so we'll hear more from
pat about the uh pat's odyssey as we are
calling it on tomorrow's friday bonus
show and we will be back with a new show
tomorrow as well very exciting